came out of north korea then you went to
university in south korea so you got
you got to see that culture as an
outsider
and then you came to the united states
and you got to see columbia university
so
what did you conclude about your time in
columbia university
what are your what were your impressions
what do you have to say to people about
what you saw
i knew oh my gosh so that four years
from 2016 to 2020
um it was a complete madness
i i became very pessimistic about
the western world after university
because
like so literally in this humanity
classes
even the economics i was studying
economics for two years and later human
rights
the the professor would send me the like
emails oh this
this class we're gonna cover this this
if it triggers you you don't have to
come to the class or don't even do the
reading
i'm a rape survivor i'm a slave i went
through so many things and they say oh
this can trigger the rape this can
trigger this
and then like they every before the
class they say let's go through
what do you want to be called your
pronouns and my
english is not that good i sometimes
mistakenly call him or she
like and then they start asking me to
say
they and then i don't know how to
incorporate in my english that pronoun
properly
and it makes me so nervous to talk in
the classroom and
one day i got into fight with my
professor she was saying
uh you know the fact that you're letting
men holding door for you
is you are giving in to their
overpowering you
and i was like you know isn't it
kindness it's a decency i over the
door for people too it's not like i'm
trying to signal that i'm powerful than
you
and she was like you're still
brainwashed from north korea
like and i was scenario of course my gpa
is gonna be affected and it's like okay
i gotta really shut up
i gotta try to do my best to get a good
gpa
so that four years i learned
to censor myself all over again
and it became ridiculous like i
literally exactly i originally risked my
life to say
what i think is right and now i'm like
in a country where four years of time
try how to be
creative safe space and be sensitive
enough so
and like where am i and it gave me a lot
of um
chaos like did i become free like was it
where am i is there any truly free place
in this world right now
well okay so you you were in this
university in korea
and korean universities are intense and
so
how would you contrast the quality of
the education that you received and
their very western influence
the south korean university so they're a
product of the western university system
so how would you contrast your
experience at the south korean
university with
colombia which is in in principle one of
the great western american institutions
educational institutions it's
so i do think south korea is way more
technical
they are way more into trying to teach
you the skill set
like if you know more giving you actual
knowledge
but okay i think americans are very
obsessed
that was my impression colombia we're
really trying to help you how to think
but almost like you would shape how you
think
they are very into shaping your minds
how you think
about something in south korean
study program was more like
oh this is a fact this is what happened
in history this is what we're gonna do
this is a modern we're gonna apply to
solve this criminal case
like you know this is how things work
but lately though
when it comes to sociology it's been
very influenced by the western like the
mainstream education so a lot of
anti-western sentiments
was definitely there i have been
somewhat oppositional i'm not exactly
like a mr go on and get along guy with
this stuff that
i don't always have the best reality
check on my own behavior
and so i'm you know i i was just
saying well okay if i if i did cause
offense then you know i i feel like it's
okay to apologize and there probably was
a better way for me to do this
some of my comments you know were leaked
or made or transmitted to other people
that weren't in the meetings
people that were in the the bypark
meeting you know
particularly my mice
is black and indigenous people of color
so they were having their separate
meeting
of faculty and students where they
received different content
and why was it separate curiosity
the rationale as i could as i can
understand it is so that
the groups that have been marginalized
won't be exposed to
you know they'll have their own thing so
that they're not exposed to the
i think the incense and possible
insensitivity of
the oppressors
that's the best i can understand the
rationale um
but it wound up happening anyway because
i suppose it would be rude of me to
point out that that's somewhat
paternalistic
you know just as yeah you know
observation that's a good one um yeah
i mean yeah totally well i guess that is
a characteristic of white supremacy
culture though paternalism
yeah so i in there i guess it's
as long as it's in a good cause then i
guess it's forgivable
yeah i found it so interesting because
the day after the meeting
there was an email that was released
that said healing resources
you know healing resources that will
help
you come to terms with what happened and
the first healing resource
on the list was a cnn interview
with a poet named damon young
and um damon young
uh you know in this interview said
things like
you know we we need to get rid of all of
capitalism
we will have to do a carpet bombing not
a carpet cleansing of society
and it was incredibly radical statements
that
were i would imagine would be
frightening to to many people
and that was listed as a healing
resource as well as well as long as the
carpet bombing only targets the
malevolent people
well yeah i guess and then things there
was a robin d'angelo article
that said you know what white people
need to be made or kept
uncomfortable how can we become more
uncomfortable um
also you know really kind of i would
just say racist characterizations of
white people
in these links um
things like you know white people have
never had to be guests in this country
and like the irish for example
they weren't really white to begin with
though so yeah
yeah um and so i found this very ironic
the idea that
especially when post-modernism and the
reconstruction and
all those attendant pseudo philosophies
uh you read milton to find out uh if he
mistreated his daughters
not this this miracle that we call
paradise lost or samson agonisties
you he read homer to find out you know
if he's a blood worshiper
this whole this whole game of taking the
great documents of western civilization
as a hunting ground for moral uh
woke offense well first of all it's
catastrophically stupid
if you have the 48 symphony of mozart or
the beethoven's fifth and the only
reason you're playing it is to find out
if either most of their beethoven had a
sexist attitude you're out of your mind
self-stop this and and the idea that
one of the great propulsions of a
certain segment of western society is
simple envy
and resentment of its success even as
those who are envious
and resentful are basically being fed
and
kept by it they go into these
institutions
with some sort of childish immature
animosity towards what you know
if you think of it the rise of thought
is is the greatest thing we have
and at the in the richest part of the
world the most prosperous
the highest institution have you been
reading some of these whiteness things
the new rules
and this is like the ones the federal
government are using to train your civil
servants you mean yes
the epidemic of of anti-racism
which is a kind of racism diversity
which is
monosyllabic if you don't have our ideas
you don't have any or you're a racist or
you're this or you're that i don't know
how a free people
have succumbed so easily and so
lethargically
to a kind of it's it's not physical
but it's a metaphysical restraint and
the cowardice about some of these but
these universities that apologize for
some professor
the new york times guy 49 years
columnist
and in an explicatory conversation
using that n word editor said no there's
nothing wrong with him but then he fired
him
the universities damned them
were the place that this this other
pandemic began
and while we're living through covert we
should also understand that
the intellectual pandemic
this goes to our heart and core uh we
are displacing ourselves by allowing
charlatans to wreck
the intellectual standards of the
western world what i've read is that
you made some claim that canada wasn't
systemically racist
that wasn't the right way of looking at
the country and
is there so and to me that means now is
that the case now that at a university
if i stand up and say that i don't
believe that
the lens of systemic racism is the
proper way to analyze canada
especially compared to other countries
that now i'm so reprehensible that i
deserve to be
suspended if a couple of people object
is that
the situation that we're looking at or
am i being too hard on the university
i have to admit i may be wrong but there
may have been a flavor for that during
that month so like it was
like like my story was sort of a
scapegoat for something that is much
bigger than
a deer a simple deer a silly deer
sometimes
we're not allowed to write serious
things or silly things or be wrong
or change our mind and your situation is
also particularly
peculiar i might say because you don't
seem to be the right sort of target for
this sort of targeting
you know because you're using the
terminology that i don't
appreciate in the least i mean you're
female you're an immigrant
you're you're at least in principle part
of the communities that the people who
push this sort of nonsense are
hypothetically trying to protect so why
is it because you are in one of these
victimized categories and you dared to
say something that wasn't
in accordance with the necessary moral
uh ideology that you've been targeted um
maybe they wanted if you read the about
of the bambi's blog
you see that that deer does not want to
fit in any group and say
and put in a box so i'm supposed to be
racialized you know be a poor
me i don't have food i don't i don't
like to be victimized personally in my
life
even now with what is happening to me i
am i
think i'm a dignified person uh so
so so in that sense um i like the term
invisible minority visible minority you
know
the terms that used to be used in quebec
my time when i immigrated
i see myself more in them and then like
like
put us divided into your this group that
group and and
um you know sectorianism
or or not like canada right so you're
supposed to be first of all you're
female so hypothetically you're
oppressed because you're female even
though
the evidence for suppression of females
in academia is very very uh
it's actually females dominate over
males in terms of numerical proportion
in
most disciplines it's not the case in
the stem fields but everywhere else it's
the case not only
especially in terms of graduates
produced it might not be the case at the
highest levels of
distinction um in the academic hierarchy
although that's changing pretty rapidly
so you should actually fit into at least
two oppressed categories female and
an immigrant right and and so and so
the rule here is that if you're in both
of those categories
victimized by the intersection between
those two categories that there's a
particular political view
you better have or else and or else in
your case is everywhere else you get
suspended
because a few people complain it's what
the hell is going on with the
administration
i don't understand what they're doing i
really don't understand i can't
understand
why they didn't have the courtesy
actually i can understand why they
didn't have the courtesy to call you
because
the sad truth is is that as soon as a
few people complain
everyone who isn't directly involved
runs scared and looks for someone to
sacrifice
no but let me tell you something what
happened at mount allison university and
is happening elsewhere
but particularly here is a symptom of
what is happening in our country or
or maybe beyond actually so i take it
like that it's a symptom that we do have
a serious problem as you said like
tenured professors
not being able to express ideas debate
ideas challenge students with ideas we
do have a big problem
you're a citizen of a free country you
have right to express yourself any way
that you see fit second of all
you're a tenured professor and your
thoughts actually protected
to a fair degree and it's protected
broadly so that you can think broadly
and the fact that this has happened
despite your tenure well i guess part of
the question that people who are
watching might be asking is why the hell
should they care about this and
the reason i believe that people should
care about this first of all is that
what happens in the universities ends up
happening everywhere else very very
rapidly
and if it can happen to someone like you
it seems to me that it can happen to
anyone at any time and any place
and this this this unbelievable
cowardice that our institutions show in
the in the face of
unwarranted allegations as long as
they're the right flavor is something
that should be tremendously worrisome to
everyone we haven't got to the bad
stuff yet um uh but it started to become
apparent to me i sort of had
the realization that this was really
going the wrong direction when we
we had a professional development
meeting and they they passed out the
you i'm sure you've seen it the pyramid
of racism
also known as the pyramid of white
supremacy and
it had this a schema it was a schema
arranged in the form of a pyramid with
genocide at the top of the pyramid
and then various layers that had
categorical names
like overt racism covert racism
minimization
indifference and then various
there must have been about 50 or 60
things sprinkled on the pyramid at
various levels
and some of the things on the pyramid um
i actually thought were
you know in many cases virtues uh
so things like um being apolitical
or things like you know um
you know there are two sides to every
story um
things that were contradictory like um
you know not believing poc
but also thinking well
my black friend said dot dot dot
so the idea that these two things were
next to each other
seemed interesting to me um also things
that were just
um you know political party plat you
know platforms
minimization we all belong to the human
race
right right that was that was
post-racial society
why can't we all just get along
prioritizing intentions over impact
that's a nice one yeah yes we could we
could talk about that for about three
weeks
yeah not believing experiences of people
of color
two sides to every story
right yeah well it's very interesting
when you look very carefully at the
words that are
lumped in with the other words let's say
right guilt by association
okay so you had this pyramid of white
supremacy
and i was asked you know what do you how
do you respond to this what do you think
about this
and i just i said i think this is
extremely destructive and horrible
schema to put in front of a child and i
will never do it
and then what's the problem with that
exactly so the kids stick with the list
why
why is that bothering you well it
it's it's because it means that
you know events the the multiplicity of
possible reasons for things that
that change that are different depending
on the actual incident
get reduced to this script of of
explanations
and only those explanations you know fit
the paradigm and only those explanations
will be considered
and and that means that you're not
making sense of the world for yourself
you're following a script you may know
the name she
is a she escaped from north korea yes
and she wrote a book called in order to
live which is an amazing book
and the book ends in 2015 but
after 2015 she
enrolled in columbia university which
was a dream of hers and a dream of her
father that she be an educated person
and she studied humanities at columbia
and i asked her what that was like and
she said that
it was a complete waste of time and
money and that she felt that she was
completely unable to utter
an opinion that was genuine the whole
time she was there
and it shocked me you know and so i
asked her very specifically
i said come on come on you you're you're
not going to tell me that
the entire time you spent in colombia
you didn't have
at least one professor or two professors
who stood out who really taught you now
she had told me during the interview
that she had encountered george orwell's
work
when she was in south korea particularly
animal farm and that was what
um partly what influenced her to start
speaking in writing
and so and she had read a lot when she
was educating herself in south korea
prior to going to
south korean university and then to
colombia so it's not like she was
unfamiliar with the potential impact of
let's say the classics on
on on on on her life on her philosophy
um but when i pressed her the best she
could do was to
identify a single biology class which
dealt with evolution
which was a complete mystery to her
given her background
because history sort of started when her
dynastic totalitarians were born
um but she said even that took a wicked
turn to the politically
correct direction by the time she was
done universities now at the humanities
level
from everything i read are a disgrace uh
the the treason of the clerks it is it
is they are so suffocated
by these arch and empty philosophies
that have no logic and are punitive
i would now i'm a person that was so
taken by the university
i almost worshipped it and now i
i tell people that have younger people
younger
children 20 21 22 don't go to the damn
university unless you're taking science
go to a trades college or just go out on
your own it's the saddest thing that has
happened
in the western world that we've allowed
second-rate minds uh political agents
propagandization as instruction we have
decimated
the soul of the university i mean look
at what joe look what animal farm did
for you
that's what reading great books does for
people you know it it illuminates their
soul
it's not optional and i'm so appalled
that
that was your experience at columbia
it's so awful
that you went through all that and
managed to get to this great university
and you know and that and that you had
to shut yourself down
and that your basic conclusion was that
it was a waste of time
now did you have courses where that
wasn't the case
did you have courses that were worth it
i i mean so one class i remember in my
senior it was called the western
civilization the music art art
one of the core that colombia had is the
western art and
she has still not for long
but then the i was excited to learn
about but i thought at the end of day
this easter the west america is in the
west right
it'll be funny if you want to study
eastern music at the end of the in the
core
and professors like who has a problem
with calling the western civilization
like art
and then every single one of them all
lifting their hands because they were
saying there are so many artists
who are greater than better than mozart
we silence them erase them all and
that's why we
have to now end up studying these like
bigots you know who are racist
and i'm like and then they were like
looking at me why are you not putting
your hands up
somebody who doesn't have the problem
with talking about western civilization
so that's like i was like do i even have
to do this to graduate and that was
of course necessary to do that course to
graduate so every
every class had an element of
being a politically correct and shaping
you how you think
and i learned how to censor myself so
right after colombia and then
i was freaked out one day like what am i
doing this is how i escaped you know
it just and so i'm so ashamed of that
that's so awful
i can't believe it you know it's no
it's no picnic to watch these
great institutions hang themselves
yeah it's
i i literally felt like it's a suicide
of civilization
like we are killing ourselves here and
and that's why like what
i mean that's what scares me is that
when i was so grateful to going to south
korea was
after them of north korea there was at
least a place that was left to be free
and all these people obsessed fighting
for
you know climate change animal rights
gender equality
transgender whatever all these things
people are fighting for
wonderful but then imagine when nobody
is freeing this world
who's gonna fight for us and that's like
what terror for me is like
imagine all of us became enslaved like
north koreans
all of us did in that system there's no
one can stand up for
any of us and i guess because i'm
always i always knew that it was
guaranteed like
when i go to camping with my friends my
friends
somehow always a confidence that they're
gonna find food
even though when they're going to the
remote area not me i
always packing this like energy bars
blah blah always with me because i know
like you can end up not having ever
order food so maybe this is a mentality
that in the west
freedom was always there somehow people
think it's gonna be miraculous they're
gonna be
always there and for me it's like no it
can be
not there that's you know that's why we
were supposed to be educating young
people we were supposed to be teaching
them that
no it's not always there it's it's
fragile and you better take care of it
because
the default condition is authoritarian
starvation
and if that isn't happening it's a
bloody miracle
yeah well i've seen this over and over
in the universities too you know it was
often the case that
it was my psychology classes where the
students learned about what happened in
stalinist soviet union in maui's china
they hadn't been taught at all
they hadn't been taught that tens of
millions of people died in china they
hadn't been taught about what happened
in north korea they hadn't been taught
about what happened in russia
it was like that never existed even
though the
cold war was all about that and it was
it's appalling it's
and and i i think you you see exactly
the same thing while you're pointing out
exactly the same thing
i've been thinking about the question of
the meaning of life and
the first objection i suppose i wrote
that arose in my mind was an objection
to the question itself because there
might not be a meaning in life there
are places where people derive meaning
and and you can list them and
it's useful practically if people are
thinking about how to organize their
life if they're unhappy and
they want to know how things might be
better i mean my observation
and obviously not only mine is that
people generally need to have a career
or a job to keep the wolf from the door
but also
to engage them productively with others
which is a primary source of meaning for
conscientious people and for creative
people alike
you need to be a you need to pursue your
education
to to flesh out your intellectual
capacity you have to take care of your
health physical and mental you
you need an intimate relationship you
need a family you need
friends you need intelligent use of your
leisure time you have to regulate your
your uh susceptibility to the
temptations that might lead you astray
drugs and alcohol and
perhaps pornography and those sorts of
things and but then
there is a a core to all that
around which these more practical
endeavors arrange themselves and that's
something like
attention to the spiritual or the
philosophical
domain or the religious domain i think
you can in some sense put all those
together and
and that might be well it might be that
the attempt to
answer explicitly or at least to address
the question of well
what is all of that practical life
in service of and you said for example
that when you were working with the
inner city kids
in halifax you were trying to help them
realize that the they were meant for the
higher things and vice versa
and someone might ask well what's the
why bother with that when you can just
bother with the skills and
it seems to me that the answer is
something like well we all have to make
decisions about how we're going to
behave in life and how we're going to
act ethically
and if you help people understand
their relationship to what's ultimately
noble then you can help them
fortify their their
resolution to do good in the world
instead of to do harm
it's it's it's it's it seems to me to be
i mean i think we're always deciding
with every decision that we make whether
we're going to do good or do harm by
action or by inaction and whether we
should do good or harm or nothing at all
i think depends to some degree on who we
think we are and and
what we're capable of and it seems to me
that the humanities
when when they're properly taught are
the study of who we could be
each of us as individuals and we need to
know that because otherwise we'll be
much less than we are
and that's not a that's not a trivial
problem it's a cataclysmic
problem i did a talk at harvard
four years ago and
i pointed out two things to the students
in the audience
one was that
a tremendous amount of civilization and
effort had gone into producing the
institution that they were now part of
and that everyone
who was part of that institution was
hoping that they would come there
and learn everything they possibly could
that was relevant and important and that
they would be the best
possible people they could be and they
would go out in the world and
do as much good as they possibly could
that was the
essential mission of the enterprise and
that was really the case and also
that learning to write in particular
was going to make them more powerful
than they could imagine
and a number of students came up to me
afterwards and said
i really wish someone would have said
that to us when we first came here
if you were going to recommend to a
young person
what they should study to prepare to be
a research a psychological researcher a
clinical psychological researcher
of your type what what's what should
what should they do at the bachelor's
level let's say what what's the right
preparation and then let's walk through
the process
bachelor masters phd postdoc because
people don't know that and
so what what do you look for in a
student at the ba
if you're looking for a master's level
student what should have they done in
their bachelor's degree i guess they
have to be
passionate and at the same time ready to
work very hard
to um clarify
how you go about understanding
what you want to to understand
so you need it's it's
both of those you need the interest and
the discipline i i guess it's
it's like that in every discipline even
a hockey player or a football player it
is if you want to be successful
yeah yeah right you need to be
interested because you have to want to
yeah and at the same time you have to
take the time
and and like
investing yourself so is it fair to say
that you taught yourself to read
and you got your ged equivalent you did
that in one year and so you were ready
to go to university at the age of
how in the world did you do that how
much time were you spending every day
studying
uh i didn't so that was a funny story i
ended up in the er and then like they
were saying you're managed
because i didn't have time to eat i
forgot to eat
so even when i was sleeping i would have
turned on the like a ted talks or npr so
i can like listen my brains just kept
working
and even when i was sleeping i would put
the books behind my pillow so the like
knowledge really going to me i was
obsessed i was
crazy you were obsessed with yeah i was
i was completely obsessed with the
learning so you're completely obsessed
with studying to the point where you're
not even eating
and and we should also just stress here
it is
definitely the case that the education
process is unbelievably competitive in
south korea as you've already pointed
out
far and above what people in in young
people in north america can imagine or
in europe for that matter
and so you were facing very very heavy
competition
so but you got obsessed to the point
where you weren't even eating
that's amazing because you i would have
thought that you would be more motivated
to eat after what you
did virtually but you were hungrier for
knowledge than for food
despite and you had been starved of both
exactly
i was uh i was working at these two i
don't know you know something called
so it's like a one dollar store in south
korea the japanese branch
so i was working there as a part-time
job and i was minor
so my mom had to give the like
authorization that should let me work
and then i was working this wedding
horse like serving food
as a waitress so i was working and then
my mom was also doing the dishes and
helping me
and i was living in these rooms in seoul
because i was studying
where underground i didn't even have a
window
and i still remember those times i was
so happy because i had a goal
like i was you know like this tiny room
where you can just stretch your feet
like bailey i'm like five times tiny
in that room i was like living there all
i had was books
with me and dream yeah well a room full
of books isn't small
exactly it was it was large yeah right
absolutely
absolutely so you got your ged
and then you applied to
university for in a competitive program
and they
there was still trouble with you getting
in but you managed it how did you manage
it and how did you decide what you were
going to do
i was going to study criminal justice
it was i saw so much injustice
and even in salsa i saw so much of it i
really wanted to understand how that
worked
you know how how what this thing is
called justice
so i'm grateful they gave me all the
opportunities to study that program and
but now uh it's uh i it's just such a
like i don't know how i was
going through all of that but somehow
back then i had a drive that i
never even knew i had so but your
experience at university go into that a
little bit more detail
well i'm glad you you elaborated that as
you did
and i i suppose not i suppose i know i
brought up that university experience in
the hope that uh
and we'll do it now down the road in
this conversation
i think outside of family that is always
principle
and will never be superseded outside of
family if there's anything that
that contributed to the way that i look
at things
and have given me lasting benefit okay
you may be familiar with samuel
johnson's remark about literature it
applies to all the arts
that it exists better to help us enjoy
life
or to enjoy it uh it fixes the mind and
when you have a real
university you get these things
i my the professor i i mentioned for
example
when he found a book it was one of our
other kesslers i won't bother to name it
he actually walked to my house on a
saturday afternoon i was just a kid
and in all of them but he came to the
little studio or sorry the student house
and
wanted me to have this book for a week
so i could read i mean this kind of
almost genuflection to the emergent or
emerging
mind of a young person is something that
stays forever so
that long winded again the university
experience is
was the strongest because the
universities then had values
they worshipped and that's a good word
not to be backed off from
they worshipped the best creations the
best fashions the best styles of thought
the best scientific uh finesse
and they they made you not made you they
induced you
entities grateful to be grateful for
what
other first-rate minds have contributed
to the temper of the entire human race
my undergraduate degree i
encountered people who were reading
these texts and
saying things about them that enabled me
to understand the things that i had
perhaps intuited
when i was younger in a more
self-conscious
rationally universal frame which of
course philosophy
is ideas are the whole
are everything you know and and the i
there should be
you should be talking about ideas based
on what make ideas
sound or unsound not not the person
who's saying them
what's your vision for ralston college
architecturally speaking
you know i would perhaps say just by
introduction that you know our analysis
and
the need for founding new institutions
is directly related to the things we've
just been speaking about the
the cultural spiritual crisis the
upstream influence of the university
over everything else
the fact that it is the epicenter of
at very best unhelpful at worst uh
downright toxic forms of ideology that
spread through
anything and everything uh that isn't uh
uh
is catastrophically beset with uh high
costs
low value and so on and so forth but our
analysis is simply that
um the uh
there is huge demand in young people for
alternatives people who are seeking
alternatives to the indoctrination and
activism
and fraudulent low value of the academy
i mean i think your own work has shown
this uh about as clearly as
anything else historically ever has that
it's a mistake to concede the
to be you know your new book you write
about the need for creative dynamism
in relation to our institutions and it
seems to me we're in
in a in a moment not only which that is
urgently necessary but also
eminently possible if we have only the
courage
to uh to to do it um
so what i would say is a few things the
first
is that ralston college has has really
four fundamental commitments
first to seek the truth with courage
second to apprehend beauty in
all of its forms third to the freedom of
speech and thought that are the
conditions of those pursuits
and finally to the the friendship or
even
fellowship that is the context for
all of these pursuits and
you know what's become clear to us
jordan over the uh the years
is of it's it's been a long uh runway
it's not easy getting a college going uh
you know anyone who thinks
that you need to go off and fight in a
war in order to undertake something
really hard of value um
can call me up and we'll have a talk
about other things other projects that
may be very very difficult
to bring into the world but uh necessary
and beautiful
um what's become clear to us in these uh
these years
of development uh uh which we're sort of
at the end of is we we now are launching
our first programs and
and first degree is that rawson college
has a double vocation
both on the one hand to be a reinvention
of the academy a place for in-person
degrees
uh a a new model for the university that
can
we hope be pretty radically disruptive
not just because we're going to change
everything but we hope that it will lead
to many other people doing
new and and different and more beautiful
and more adequate and perhaps cheaper
and faster
but above all just more important and
higher value
things in the space of higher education
so on the one hand to be a reinvention
of
the uh the the academy a reinvention and
a revival of the academy
uh but and on that side we've received
our degree granting powers from the
state of georgia
we expect to launch our first degree
this autumn
in what in what this first degree will
be a masters in the humanities so it
will be a
pretty intensive boot camp in thinking
about the big ideas tracing them and
their development
through history uh which we think is
important both as a revival of those
forms of
life and thought and culture but also
because we think they
are the as it were the key to opening up
the
uh depths of the self for the students
themselves
um you know it's not that every human if
i can't play the piano
it's not that every um you talk about
resentment earlier you know it's not
that every
uh human being should have to play the
piano like martha arguary
or glenn gould uh from your home your
your current town of toronto
um uh 99.999 percent of
human individuals couldn't play the
piano that way but because glenn
gould could and did we can all hear the
music
and in some level i think
what the the the the high
end of the academy is about is about
playing the music so we can all
hear it and uh and and so on the one
hand
it's the reinvention of the academy um
in in
in a degree form but on the other hand
the second side of this double vocation
is to be a kind of platform of
humanistic inquiry
for anyone anywhere who which is wishes
to engage with the
the riches of the humanistic tradition
who wishes to seek the truth with
courage who
who is who is who wishes to ask the
fundamental
human questions that that that every
human being must face
about truth and beauty and forgiveness
and
love and suffering to me the
universities
are the a key element in the
conversation across
the generations about just exactly what
a human being is and
and that's something that it's not some
abstract philosophical
it's not merely some abstract
philosophical concern it's
it's the central issue that determines
how you make all the decisions in your
life